go here's video uh on New Year's Day
protesters uh at the Rose Parade in
[Music]
[Applause]
Pasadena
team
[Music]
team I'm going to ask you
[Applause]
[Music]
Colin I'm fairly certain that if Israel
was losing they would not be calling for
a ceasefire they'd be pretty thrilled
but that aside how long do you think a
society can hold when on any given day
any group with whatever their grievances
can shut down a bridge shut down an
airport shut down a parade uh stop
people from going into a mall etc etc
this that to me seems like the issue
that we're they're sort of testing what
western societies are willing to
tolerate and I think we're failing the
test exactly I mean it it's it's
mind-boggling how we don't just enforce
the the law as written and remove people
from streets who blocking you know the
flow of traffic um you know I'm actually
going to count this as another win you
know we've been trying to tally some
wins going on here it might seem like
hard to find a win out of all of this
but there is a silver lining in this
because I think with regard to the whole
Palestine and Hamas and all this stuff
the woke left's mask has completely
fallen off here their aggressive
ideology is fully exposed we see the
woke identitarian ideologies like CRT
and decolonization we see where these
things lead where they sort of have the
simplified oppressor oppressed you know
being a DEC colonizer uh apparently
means you can justify anything against
colonizers including rape and murder
it's it's woken up so many liberals
moderate liberals from the dangers of
wokeness and I believe we've reached a
Tipping Point here we've waited for a
sort of mass Awakening to push back
against the threat of the great
awokening like we've had gay ousted more
universities are ejecting Dei
corporations are too we need need to
ensure that this momentum doesn't lead
up you know Dei capitalized on the
momentum from George Floyd's death uh
pushed the radical ideology far and wide
now it's our turn to sort of March it
back to where it was you know not only
where it was but you know back out of
America for good I think so I think this
is a win um and we're going to see uh
some improvements from here at least I
hope